in this video JC talks to us about house
soil health and changing his crop
rotations and introducing animals has
actually made money for JC also talks
about infiltration rates which he
frequently measures on his pot the
procedure JC uses is to take a six inch
ring hammer it into the ground and then
measure the time it takes for one inch
of water to infiltrate and even if you
break even on your small grain when you
look at the the yield bump you get on
your core and your soybean crop after
that and and also if your grazing after
your small grain your profitability goes
up even though you broke even the one
year you still make more than you would
have in the two year rotation so
basically here we're in a corn soybean
oat rotation I used to do Rai but the
profits kind of come out of Rai in the
last few years now the reason that I
pick oats is we raise it as a seed crop
and then we we started a seed cleaning
operation now to where we actually have
an air screen and a gravity table and we
clean it and sell it as a clean product
and so oh it's works good for us we what
I really like about the three-year
rotation is that since we brought in
this third crop our corn yields have
gone corn soybean yields have gone up
significantly within a three-year span
my my soybean yields probably went up
three to five bushel an acre across the
fire may average and corn ten to twelve
I would have to say that's maybe be and
I mean that's right in there and that's
pretty they've been pretty consistent
our infiltration rates have increased
and when you raise that oats it also
gives you a chance to diversify your
modes of action your herbicides so the
idea is to try and kind of cut down
sand-like waterhemp particularly what I
really like about oats is now we have an
opportunity to cover crop in it you know
the Jim and I are putting up fences and
this way we can bring livestock back
into the system is just another factor
which is gonna drive that soil health
you know I know I had gone to some other
workshops the past they talked about
that our soil doesn't have enough
microbes in it and then the best way to
bring them back is to bring animals back
on back into the rotation but it adds a
level of profitability so here you're
you're raising a third crop that helps
increase all the yields on all three
then you turn around put a cover crop in
it drive soil health and you can graze
animals on it then you know build a
level of productivity back into that and
it kind of works at all in those
basically systems approach is what it is
cover crops that I like best I guess for
us is would be putting like a riot and a
rapeseed mix in after the oh it's no
tilling beans and a rye is just it's
just you can't believe the difference
between that and just going in this
straight for itself
[Music]
you